I guess the worst I'm gonna find a
billionaire is done is probably pretty
easy to think about it yeah I mean yeah
yeah there's I mean you know
hilarious stuff though yeah that's the
problem I did like that the Amazon guy
tried to fly the moon in a penis it
should have been a bigger penis yeah and
it should have you know but what the uh
what was it called again that his ship
spaceship yeah yeah but like they're not
doing a fun bit Bezos is embracing the
villain which I like he's embracing and
he's going listen I'm bald
I'm taking everybody's jobs now gonna be
a drone no matter your aunt worked at
[ __ ] Safeway packing macaroni salad
that's gonna be a robot the Drone is
going to take the macaroni salad your
Thanksgiving pie is gonna get delivered
by just like a a predator drone that's
going to drop it to you nobody's gonna
work anymore nobody needs to I'm gonna
own all of the grocery stores all the
retail stores you're never gonna have to
leave your house strip malls all that
[ __ ] commercial real estate it's gonna
tank everything will be Amazon
warehouses I think that's kind of his
vision yeah so you can't be that guy and
also not embrace the yacht the hose like
embrace it yeah I can't stop shopping
yeah his success is kind of predicated a
little bit on everybody you know kind of
losing a job right everybody you know
there's not villainy enough man yeah
Hazel's building with your head on it
that's the layer there's this layer
that's coming they have layer he has a
layer multiple layers but you can't like
a real nice house with a couple bricks
some of them get weird weird I want to
see Jeff Bezos holding this like Jesus
get Jeff bezos's house some of them get
where you start going it's a little Tony
Stark it's a little I want some Doctor
Doom [ __ ] yeah go to the cape I mean
some of them are right there 165 mil up
there that house right there I mean yeah
it's still respect but that's you know
that's you're doing it at that point
Jeff Bezos needs to come out in a black
cloak and a monocle and just go this is
who I am now but here's the thing that
we don't want to we don't want to DARE
them to do it because they will do it
that's kind of fun like that's the thing
it's like they will do it we will see
trillionaires In Our Lifetime yeah we
will see people that have more money and
we're already seeing it than entire gdps
of countries we are gonna see
people we're going to see a level of
luxury that people are living in we're
already seeing space tourism people
going I want to get to space yeah all
the while we're also seeing like a lot
of other crazy [ __ ] happening in the
inner cities where people can't get
clean water you're seeing these guys go
we're kind of tired of this planet yeah
they're that's kind of what they're
doing like all the big billionaires now
they're like listen the the billionaires
in the past weren't great either but
they built railroads they built schools
they used to do cool [ __ ] yeah these
guys now are kind of like to be honest
we're a little bored with Earth let's
just a little bored what are we gonna do
we're gonna buy another house in Malibu
I know another house Another Hawaiian
island who cares we're bored get us out
of here they're trying to leave the
planet got through a shittier Planet
they're trying to leave the planet and
listen one of my favorite things is like
they always ask people like they always
bring scientists and all these weird
people together and go where's Climate
Change Gonna head because we want to be
somewhere else yeah so they start
building compounds I know a big real too
says they all want compounds with their
own water aquifiers they want 50 100
acres of land they're all going to
Montana they're all why do you think
you're going to Montana they're going to
Yellowstone I didn't know that who's I
know you're talking about go to Wyoming
billionaires really billionaires they
want space and they want compounds yeah
that's what they're doing that sucks
oh that guy's a [ __ ] yeah I mean
that's that's lairish I mean that's
Hogwarts that's nice it's where he would
live it is a Hogwarts no I want to walk
in it's all like metal you want to raise
her house but this is where Alicia Keys
live go to the razor house razor house
it's in La Jolla in San Diego I know you
yeah she lived there Swiss beats and her
live there go to the razor house this is
where you want them to live look at the
Google image of the Razer house right
here that's what you want the razor
house that's pretty cool like that type
of just Stone and glass Google Mustafar
this is where I want to be this is where
I think Jeff Bezos should be interesting
m-u-s-d
where is this
most of our well you'll see okay
um this is the kind of [ __ ]
this is where people this is where this
is where the Darth Vader lives
it's it's just a lava I forget it how
much of a nerd you are which I love this
yeah yeah so you were a lava hump what a
lava home that is cold there's no
windows and there's no one else on the
planet yeah just death
but it's like here's what I look at
here's what I think about every now and
then and maybe it's better maybe what
he's doing is better because you walk
into a supermarket and you see somebody
with Down syndrome and you're making
like they're putting the potato salad in
the thing and you say to yourself maybe
they shouldn't have to do this and maybe
Bezos is going to free them from that
right and or you'll see a woman who's
like a hundred she's really old and
they'll be like she's worked here 47
years and we love Irma yeah and and Irma
celebrated her 40th year with the HEB
grocery chain last year she's seen her
kids go to jail and her husband's two
husbands die and she's just still
walking with a hump where she's almost
fully uh uh uh a [ __ ] horseshoe
upside down and she's just walking
around the deli counter and have you
ever asked any of those people for help
because it's sad and it's hard but
sometimes you need to find something and
you ask one of those people for help and
it's literally like to like
and you go hi
do you have any Pepper Jack and they go
and they're just emerging from like this
very scary sad place that you're and
you're like and there because at that
moment they were in like some days and
she's remembering when she could dance
and when the president wasn't black or
whatever and she's she then comes out of
it she goes and then a lot of times
they'll just point she's just gonna
and then she just keeps going and it's
hard so maybe grocery store because some
of the most disturbing things I've ever
seen in my life have been an American
chain grocery stores I have seen things
in a Publix that have should that have
sure I'm a cokehead my mother's a
schizophrenic
um I was a closeted gay guy that I was
25 I was a drunk I had a house at
foreclosed on I was a mess right and all
those things are still in my head and I
hung out and cracked I've seen like
people not at their best let's just say
I've seen people that are not at their
back sure their mother's still lying in
a bed like out of it and all that [ __ ]
and I deal with it with humor and I try
to do but it's it's [ __ ] up
the things I've seen in a Publix outside
of Orlando
have scared me on a level where like I
go maybe Bezos is it wrong to just get
rid of this right to just eliminate it
to where because the things I've seen
the types of people that just emerge I
mean you say eliminate you mean uh how
are you it just comes the food just
comes you don't see a guy who's dope I
thought you meant eliminating them as
people I saw a guy in Publix just I
don't mean eliminate them as people but
I saw a guy in the Publix to sunken in
eyes blue he comes out he's still got
his hood you know you see the thing with
their their half dressed like they're
working at the deli counter but then
they also have the hoodie yeah and he
comes in with the hoodie
there's a head he's tatted up and he's
got to put on the plastic bags yeah
honestly and you try not to look at the
hands because you go okay and I want to
look at those don't touch my hands you
don't want to look at the things and the
arms because there's things that have
happened maybe and he's just kind of out
of it and he's like man and he's just
scooping stuff and he's trying to weigh
it out and you go like you're like this
is this is tough yeah yeah yeah this is
tough yeah this is tougher because it's
his first job out of rehab yeah it's and
he's still any and he relapsed three
hours ago and he's [ __ ] up
and he's in a Publix and you're staring
at him and you go hey man I'd like this
I'd like that and he's just staring at
you and so some of those things I do
where I see mentally impaired people
working and I go they shouldn't have to
work right
and everyone goes no they like it and
it's our country it's like they actually
like it gives them a sense of purpose
does does it sure but I've seen some
things in those stores where I go if
that's what he's eliminating
it's okay maybe it's okay maybe everyone
just needs a stipend they can live in
their house nobody really likes jobs I
think food and that [ __ ] should just be
easier to get I mean it's crazy does
anyone want to work at Marshalls does
anyone want to deal with me working
walking in going do you where's the big
and tall and they go I don't know dude
it's a few shirts on the floor find it
or not it's like does anyone want that
gig you know get the robots those jobs I
want a robot to size me up at a [ __ ]
yeah yeah look at this look at this
create a blood-covered man walks into
Florida Publix after stabbing two people
it's where people go when they're at
their lowest point I just found out
about Publix and I really knew about it
yeah I've just been informed of this and
they have a great clubs their sandwich
is fine it's okay people make way too
much out of the Publix Club you know
it's chicken and whatever and sauce they
they put it in a bag they take the
chicken Cutters they cut them off they
put them in a bag with like Ranch and
buffalo sauce and then they shake it and
then a woman like shakes it and then she
pours it onto a very soft bun and rolls
it up and it you know listen it's not
the worst thing in the world but people
really get excited about this and maybe
if Bezos is getting rid of this like
maybe if he doesn't want this anymore
he's like getting rid of them as people
are giving them money so they can
survive you keep saying getting rid of
them is people I'm just confused on what
you're saying he's eliminating them as
like as workers oh okay so so in a good
way Mullen used to always tell me about
this [ __ ] fully luxury automated
communism or whatever where Ubi they all
just Ubi right they all just get look
man shot by Deputy after trying to enter
Green Acres Publix
while armed has died I mean so it's like
it it maybe we don't need this anymore
yeah no I agree maybe it's gotten to a
point where Bezos and his wisdom has
gone how many more stabbings do you want
to see
how many more Trails of blood in the
Frozen aisle do you really want to see
before we're done and if that's the goal
and also these retail stores
nobody buys any club if you buy clothes
in a store now you're like a freak
most people buy them online I go to DXL
the fat store it's horrible yeah yeah
it's it's bad and that's why I just
hired a trainer I don't want to go to
that store anymore yeah you see guys
they're 500 pounds they just they get
this big shirt it's like a 7x it's just
like a tent that goes on them and then
it just has like the Ralph Lauren polo
logo that they've blown up to 7x it's
pixelated
it's the biggest Polo you can't even
tell it's a horse you don't know what
kind of animal it is you can't tell it's
a guy on a pores yeah and it's just this
big guy and he's waddling around and
he's always got like some somebody with
them yeah kind of like a wife-ish thing
like a woman there who's like yeah it's
tough yeah yeah it's tough that's why
the fat activist movement like I don't
think fat people should be disrespected
but like it's hard right when I watch a
19 year old kid walking in DXL and he's
a big boy yeah and they're trying to and
and his mom's got there because they're
trying to make him feel good for the
prom and he comes in and he's big and he
knows that prom night's not ending with
[ __ ] he knows that no matter how good
he and the mom will say cute things
she'll be like well it this is for the
ladies yeah and he's like listen I have
a rash I have a rash on my inner thigh I
have pustules you know what they are
they're exploding and goo is dripping
down the my thigh and the mom will
always be like you could look good for
the ladies and he's like okay and he's
got this like five acts four accident
it's hard and I know me and you we like
to eat sure but it is difficult so maybe
that short store should not exist yeah
yeah yeah if they could help out that'd
be great it's always a very friendly
like Jamaican woman when I walk in she's
like how you doing I'm like I'm I'm
still here yeah let me know if you need
anything oh you look good in that I'm
like no I don't yeah but she's sweet
yeah so maybe it's like instead of
getting mad about Bezos it's like maybe
the things that he's taking away we
would just be better off in our houses
sure yeah maybe not no I I agree I have
nothing more to add you know I don't
know
it's just
it's just it's just like Commerce in
America is not fun right Commerce is not
fun anymore like there's nothing like if
you're hot that's addiction now if
you're hot and Rich everything's fun
yeah and you could go to Christian Dior
and they're like
and you go yes but for most people yeah
going out and trying to find anything
it's just not a good time